[Music]
thank you
oh we can smell it
that's 1870.
so when you count between 1935 and 1950
you have 15 years you can count like
tree rings and all the way to the top
[Music]
they may relate to things like burning
of fossil fuels it could relate to
industrial pollution from certain
activities it can relate to agricultural
change particularly the greater usage of
artificial nitrogen-based fertilizers
[Music]
during the atomic bomb testing they were
actually measuring plutonium levels in
the atmosphere well we can actually see
a parallel curve of plutonium in the in
the mud sediments in the bottom of the
lake
[Music]
thank you foreign
is to say no actually humans are a major
geological Force
um and if anything probably the most
significant georgical thoughts on the
planet if they accept that there is a
fundamental change that's due to humans
then maybe
action will be taken
[Music]